[Music]
foreign the Netherlands is a small
country seen as utopia great
infrastructure unparalleled government
graphic design and an immense amount of
Economic and Engineering power
concentrated in a small well-managed
piece of land
but the Netherlands is not a perfect
country it's currently facing one of the
worst housing crisis in the world its
governing parties aren't really trusted
after falsely charging thousands of
parents with abusing Child Benefits a
country that is expected to manage well
but manage Corona just pretty badly one
that's known for being egalitarian but
is seeing increasing inequality and it's
a country that many feel lacks an
adequate Vision in a world that requires
Direction sure it can compromise on some
nice things but it can act quickly on
few the Netherlands is not perfect
unfortunately for you a random college
student in a basement has managed to
figure out exactly what's wrong with it
I have all the answers
see the Dutch personality is a blend
between priest and Merchant and also an
angry old man on the one hand an
undeniable feeling of original sin the
Dutch must avoid arrogance and vanity at
all costs where you risk the danger of
standing out from the crowd normalcy is
not boring it's encouraged
on the other hand you have the merchant
a deep pragmatism and efficient work
ethic little waste and a deep focus on
function were the frugality that
produces thick wallets forget ordering
in mashed potatoes with carrots is more
than sufficient but between them is also
that angry old man that voices their
concerns nitpicks and complains about
everything in a bluntness that has
become accepted because that's just
that's just you know how they are and
it's that blend of characters that helps
us understand where the netherlands's
strengths begin but where its biggest
weaknesses lie
in the holders River area are two
districts boomerular vart and over beta
in the 16 and 1700s both faced the risk
of severe flooding
so they did what the Dutch do best Bill
Dykes but the two districts were not the
same
overbatua had larger farms and more
extensive Estates was more unequal than
bomolervard where a large portion of
farmers worked smaller plots that they
own directly and some beulavide Villages
less than 40 percent of the land
belonged to the nobility in institutions
but an overbatua it was more than 70.
the two districts had different
societies with different levels of
inequality but still there was something
that United them a desire not to be
killed by water
the Netherlands lies on the North Sea
where dangerous water is a fact of life
the land was first populated by the
fries modern-day friesians called
watermen by the Romans who built their
homes on Terrapin primitive mounds of
easily manipulate clay and peat that
would protect them from Storm surges but
the water mud men were an Innovative and
Restless Bunch Terrapin combined which
made room for larger Villages that
constructed smaller dikes to protect
crops than entire sea walls along with
emergency Dykes coins slavskates and the
one and only pulled her
the polder is one of the most
recognizable features of the Netherlands
build a wall around water and use a
pumping system to pump water out Dutch
people manipulate water it's a story
most know but what we forget is the
reverse direction of the relationship
how water changed through the Dutch are
themselves
building dikes isn't easy but building
the institutions that regulate that
water management is harder dikes are the
difference between life and death and a
single person cannot maintain a system
of dikes on their own so Dykes gave
birth to Dyke solidarity entire
communities be you rich or poor farmer
or urbanite Protestant or Catholic were
tasked with relying on each other for
dike maintenance if the dike went down
you'd all drown communities establish
water boards where everyone could voice
and deliberate about water management
and a culture of open discussion
nitpicking and consensus had to develop
Farmers needed to know if their
neighbors were holding up their side of
the bargain and if someone was an
adventurous type who wanted to expand
the land and change something about it
it'd be very possible that they could
produce disastrous consequences for
another so consensus for large-scale
decisions became even more important not
being normal was a liability
and that brings us back to Boomer of
ours and over betua they were different
in their levels of inequality but in the
more unequal over Bay to the craftsmen
who worked on the land sat on the same
water board as those who owned the land
they worked on in Boomer of art nearly
50 percent of households held positions
on the Village Council tasked with
managing water at some point in their
lives and an overbatua it was the same
the looming danger of Water Gave room
for political equality when economic
inequality did not irrespective of
property or social class hundreds of
years ago the Dutch afforded large
sections of its population a right to
nitpick and endlessly discuss how water
would be managed the precursor for the
Dutch system of pragmatic agreement and
consensus that exists to this day the
boulder model a system of consensus
politics that is like no other on Earth
Coalition governments are governments
where a single party is not able to
secure a majority of seats and to pass
legislation they need to form a
coalition with others to end up with a
majority after an election the Dutch
Parliament the Toyota Camry will point
for Kenner that investigates potential
combinations of parties that can form a
coalition when a potential combination
is found a new person the informator
will be appointed to guide the
negotiations between those parties the
informator together with the Coalition
parties will begin drafting a coalition
agreement which will then steer
government policy for the years that
that Coalition is in power
now a similar process is practiced by
others sure but Dutch Coalition
Agreements are among the most elaborate
not only are they able to secure some of
the most precisely defined deals that
exist but the Dutch take Coalition deals
more seriously than most
this graph shows the time it takes to
form a political Coalition in Europe and
the Netherlands stands out on top now
you have Belgium sometimes but Belgium
is Belgium
but Dutch Coalition times are not a good
thing an agreement in the end sure but
it also reflects a system that isn't
perfect one where it has become even
more difficult to form coalitions and
produce policy and one that isn't
getting any better
the Netherlands used to be led by a big
three vivide Seria and pivria the
merchant priest and old angry man
respectively although they were
criticized for party dominance the push
and pull between all three provided
stability for the Coalition governments
a loss of one would be made up by the
other two in the next
although they still Market each other as
parasites they're actually pretty
codependent on each other but the big
three have declined and in its place the
number of parties has gone into
overdrive with 150 seats the Tomato
camera has 16 political parties
that's a lot for a small country
caused in part by the country being
essentially one gigantic district with
proportional voting all 150 seats will
be distributed across all the votes but
what makes the Dutch system uniquely
prone to producing more parties is that
it also has one of the lowest thresholds
to enter Parliament that exists 0.67
percent the equivalent of one seat one
of the purest examples of trying to give
everyone a seat at the table in Germany
if you don't get around five percent of
the vote you're not getting access to
Laguna stock either
and these new smaller parties although
they may be derivative of another still
need to set themselves apart you end up
with parties like 50 plus a party for
the elderly and also a party for the
animals one of the first of its kind
volt fragments the left liberal days has
incestor because it gives Dutch
University students with the personality
of a root vegetable more character by
letting them find all their meaning in
European integration and altogether the
fragmentation of parties into smaller
ones makes a it more difficult to form
coalitions the consensus needed to guide
the country
the boulder model is no longer an
advantage it's a penalty
this graph shows the number of
parliamentarians relative to population
and stubborn country she is the
Netherlands likes to stand apart it's a
small country but it has even smaller
numbers of people to represent the
population on the national level
a large party although at risk of
dominating and being boring can breed
specialization of members in the Toyota
Camry and better control the governing
cabinet if they're in the opposition
it's not easy to have experts on
financial education foreign and green
energy policy with only one or two
people unless they're Youtubers of
course who are experts on everything
add on the problem that there aren't
enough support staff for
parliamentarians to make up for the lack
of members in the Toyota Camry and you
end up with one of the largest issues
for the Netherlands no longer the dry
effective pragmatic chamber it once was
it's instead seen a steep rise in motis
literally just official political
statements instead of experienced dry
consensus Builders you get politicians
that fling easy dramatic political
rhetoric Dutch parliamentarians spend
more time signaling what they believe in
rather than getting laws passed that
actually achieve it a rise in empty
marketing politics and a system that
isn't built for it maybe it's an
experienced thing politicians just need
time to gain more experience so they can
produce effective legislation instead of
crafting viral tweets but instead the
Netherlands has seen a historic rise in
politician turnover politicians leave
the trade a camera faster than they have
before
so what you get is more parties less
experienced legislators which means less
experienced Coalition Builders and then
you hand them an especially thick set of
problems that they need to solve be it
housing Corona or an influx of refugees
but if it can't handle those problems
what you get is a historic rise in
distrust the strong consensus pragmatic
nature of the Netherlands works well
when the priest Merchant and angry old
man work together but it struggles when
they compete for top of the Heap too
much of the old angry man led to a
housing crisis constant critical
nitpicking has a knack of being easier
than actually building and today the
Netherlands is blessed with one of the
least elastic housing supplies that
exists in the world
too much of the priest meant a Corona
crisis where no person felt arrogant
enough to take the lead even when the
speed of a decision was a question
between life and death
and too much of the merchant meant that
when Europe cried for fiscal solidarity
the Dutch just said no like a cheese
sandwich every day for lunch another
example of Dutch frugality taken to such
an extreme that it's embarrassing
so a priest Merchant an old man walk
into a boulder and they start to
complain the merchant says we saved up a
bunch of money by never cooking anything
remotely delicious so we can build
something we should probably build
something so the priest nervously
replies why why should I build something
you have to be pretty arrogant to
suggest that you can build something but
then the old angry man interrupts
because he feels like he's not being
heard well if something's going to be
built we better be in agreement and get
it right because I don't want to build
anything I don't agree with and I want
to make sure that this tiny irrelevant
detail is met before I start doing
anything and so they begin to argue as
they have for hundreds of years but what
has made the Netherlands special is that
if they can temper those differences in
order to produce a result that result
can often be better than the three give
credit to
almost a year ago I signed up for a
streaming service to watch only one
video and that's this one made by Neo a
single person behind a computer has
produced one of the best videos I've
seen on the attack he covers an
extremely sensitive political topic
while staying close to reality and there
are literally only a handful of people
on the entire internet who will explain
current events by making 3D models like
Neo does
and that video is only possible because
along with hundreds of others it's
exclusively on nebula a streamy award
nominated independently created
streaming service that has no ads and
the best way to get access to nebula is
by signing up for the Curiosity stream
nebula bundle for less than 15 a year
you don't just get nebula but curiosity
stream gives you access to thousands of
new documentaries like the one on the
nine Mass Delta if I didn't quench your
thirst for polders curiosity stream
surely will
if you want to help me make videos on
Europe and other independent creators
the best way to do it is by signing up
for the bundle at curiositystream.com
it's worth it I was subscribe to both
before I was even sponsored by them